aquí tenemos a cuatro hermanos el más
grande guille está encargado de
seleccionar quién va a lavar los trastes
después de cada cena en la casa y bueno
la idea de guille es para hacer este
proceso justo vamos a poner todos los
nombres en un tazón y cada noche vamos a
seleccionar uno al azar así que elegí me
lo pongo ahí está el tazón
ella es tan tazón y aquí están los
cuatro papelitos con los cuatro nombres
de los cuatro hermanos de modo que todos
los nombres tienen la misma probabilidad
de ser seleccionados esto fue la idea de
ji ji
guillermo como ustedes prefieran pero
bueno entonces lo que sucede es lo
siguiente la primera noche lo hacen y
todos felices la segunda también pero la
tercera noche que se han dado cuenta que
guillén no ha sido seleccionado en
ninguna de las tres noches que han
pasado entonces los demás hermanos dicen
quizás aquí hay algo raro pero no tienen
desconfiar de su hermano mayor no
quieren desconfiar de guille así que se
preguntan bueno cuál es la probabilidad
cuál es la probabilidad de que guillén
no haya sido seleccionado en tres noches
consecutivas así que básicamente la
situación que tenemos es la siguiente
vamos a suponer que el proceso de
selección es aleatorio así que suponemos
suponemos
un proceso aleatorio un proceso
aleatorio es decir no hay ninguna
influencia en de qué manera se sacan los
papeles y todos los cuatro nombres
tienen la misma posibilidad de ser
seleccionados entonces primero
consideremos cuál es la probabilidad
cuál es la probabilidad de que guillén
no sea seleccionado en una noche dada
así que la probabilidad de que guillén
no sea
no se ha seleccionado
seleccionado
una noche
esta es una noche cualquiera noten que
los eventos son independientes y bueno
cuál es la probabilidad de que guillén
no sea seleccionado pues tenemos cuatro
eventos posibles que son los cuatro
nombres cuatro eventos posibles y de
ellos tres nombres no son el de guille
así que 3 de 4 nos dan un resultado que
no es guille así que la probabilidad de
que guillén no sea seleccionado en una
noche cualquiera es de tres cuartos
ahora sí cuál es la probabilidad de que
guillén
guille no se ha seleccionado
no se ha seleccionado
en tres noches consecutivas
en tres noches
consecutivas consecutivas
cuál es esa probabilidad pues como les
decía las probabilidades de cada noche
son independientes cada noche
seleccionan un nombre y lo regresan a la
siguiente noche se repite como este
proceso es aleatorio y es independiente
la probabilidad de que guillén no sea
seleccionado tres noches consecutivas es
la probabilidad de que no sea
seleccionado en una noche por la
probabilidad de que no sea seleccionada
en una noche por la probabilidad de que
no sea seleccionado en una noche así que
esta probabilidad es igual a tres
cuartos
tres cuartos por tres cuartos 3 x 3 x 3
es 27
y 4 por 4 por 4 es 4 por 4 16 por 4 64 y
cuánto es eso muy bien y con nuestra
calculadora vamos a hacer 27 entre 64 y
eso es 0.42 18 0.42 digamos así que esto
es aproximadamente 0.42 que es igual al
42% realmente no cuestionaría la
honestidad de alguien si hay un 42%
posibilidades de que realmente no esté
haciendo trampa no es suficiente para
cuestionar la integridad de guille así
que supongamos que siguen haciéndolo lo
siguen haciendo por varias noches pero
después de 12 noches djs sigue sin ser
seleccionado así que ahora quiero
averiguar cuál es la probabilidad de que
guillén
guille no se ha seleccionado no se ha
seleccionado
abreviar los no se ha seleccionado 12
noches consecutivas 12 noches
consecutivas
y pues bueno cuánto sería esto sería
tres cuartos por tres cuartos por tres
cuartos por tres cuartos doce veces cada
noche tiene una probabilidad de tres
cuartos de no ser seleccionado y son
eventos independientes así que este
número es igual a tres cuartos a la 12 y
cuánto es eso bien así que con nuestra
calculadora vamos a hacer 3 entre 4
elevado noten los paréntesis a la 12 3
entre 4 elevado a la potencia 12
0.3 16 vamos a redondear lo a 0.0 32 así
que esto es aproximadamente 0.0 32 o lo
que es lo mismo es un 3.2 por ciento de
probabilidad de que guillén no haya sido
seleccionado 12 noches consecutivas por
lo tanto realmente en este punto así
puedes empezar a cuestionar la
integridad de guillén la probabilidad de
que esto pase es muy muy baja como para
que este evento o este proceso de
selección realmente sea aleatorio de
hecho esto es lo que hacen muchas veces
los estadistas dicen bueno
supongo que algo es aleatorio entonces
me fijo en un evento y si ese evento
tiene probabilidad menor a 5% pero está
sucediendo entonces la cosa no es
aleatoria si hay más del 5% probabilidad
que suceda entonces realmente no puedo
decir que no sea aleatorio pero ese 5%
es quizás he elegido un poco
arbitrariamente en este caso lo que
podemos decir es que la probabilidad es
muy muy pequeña y por lo tanto podemos
pensar que nuestra su posición inicial
que era un proceso aleatorio quizás está
equivocada quizás dije si hizo trampa y
si este fenómeno continuará ocurriendo
si por ejemplo guillén no fuera
seleccionado 20 noches consecutivas esta
probabilidad sería prácticamente cero
así que si eso pasará definitivamente
bueno no definitivamente pero la
suposición de que el proceso es
aleatorio realmente podría ser
cuestionada con mucha mucha fuerza